[Musique]
sébastien corps de longueuil a reçu un
courriel prétendument de l'entreprise de
stationnement mmorpg qui lui annonce
qu'il n'a pas payer une contravention de
40 dollars émise par la ville de toronto
parce qu'il aurait mal garé sa voiture
il a vu tout de suite que c'est une
arnaque parce qu'il n'est jamais allé à
toronto
l'histoire devrait s'arrêter là mais il
y a dans ce courriel un piège dans
lequel tout le monde peut tomber le
courriel dit d'abord en preuve des
photos de sa voiture mal stationnée
il peut même voir les photos en cliquant
ici avouez que c'est difficile de ne pas
cliquer juste pour voir s'il n'aurait
pas vraiment une photo de votre voiture
même si vous savez que c'est impossible
mais il ne faut pas le faire parce que
ce ne sera pas une photo un logiciel
malveillant qui sera téléchargée dans
l'ordinateur ou le téléphone quand vous
serez cliquez là dessus il sera trop
tard
dans le pire des scénarios ces logiciels
malveillants s'infiltre dans
l'ordinateur et menacent de détruire vos
données si vous ne payez pas une rançon
quand vous passez la souris sur le lien
sans clic et vous voyez l'adresse du
lien en bas de l'écran
vous pouvez ensuite faire votre enquête
sur cette adresse ou encore effacer tout
ça sans même ouvrir quoi que ce soit
merci à sébastien caron et si vous aussi
vous avez failli vous en faire passer un
set de nous